[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يشددوا على ضروره
التعامل العسكري والاستخباراتيه الدولي ضد
ايران
عن استقالته من رئاسه مجلس اداره تويتر
ولا بيان رسمي حول مستقبل المنصب
القذفات الامريكيه بي 20 فايف والمقاتلات
اب 22 تنضم الى مناورات مشتركه مع كوريا
الجنوبيه
والمنتخب الارجنتيني يصل مطار العاصمه
واحتفالات شعبيه ضخمه في استقباله
اهلا بكم ننتقل مباشره مشاهدينا الى
الرئيس السوداني المعزول عمر البشير الذي
يدلي بافادته لاول مره منذ الاطاحه به
امام القضاء
وكل انجاز
ده كان حدث كبير عليك
وبقول الو انا بتحمل
كل المسؤوليه
اما تم في 30 يونيو
واعلم انه الاعتراف هو سيد الادله
وكنت اتابع محاولات هيئه الاتهام
لاثبات هذه التهمه
فيديوهات
وجهود التهام
وانا باسمع وبستمتع
لكن عايز اثبت حقيقه
قال له كله يا اخواننا اعضاء مجلس الثوره
الموجودين هنا
في هذه القاعه
ما كان عندهم اي دور
في التخطيط او التنفيذ
وانما تم اختياره كوكب من غير الضباط
القوات المسلحه عشان يمثل وحدات وتمثيل
في التخطيط ولا في التنفيذ
ولا التنفيذ
وانما تم اختياره
بعد لانه هو كوكبه من غير الضباط القوات
ايضا
انه ما في اي مدينه دخل معنا
عمل عسكري بحث
من اي مدينه تشاركوا معنا في تخطيطنا في
تنفيذ
لكن احنا ما كان
وحده من برنامج السلطه
محتاجين خبرات وكفاءات
عشان ما تدير البرد في الظروف الصعبه
عشان كده كان
برنامجيه
هو انا نفتح
حوار مع كل القوات السياسيه
عشان كده احنا كان عندنا توجيه صغار جدا
للضباط المسؤولين
من الاعتقالات
لاي واحد من القيادات الثقيله
والاعتقال كان عنده هدف واحد هي مساله
تامينيه في بدايه التحرك
معامله
المعتقلين
لانه بقى عايزين واحده
[موسيقى]
بجانب من كلمه عمر البشير الذي يدلي
بشهادته او افادته لاول مره امام القضاء
منذ الاطاحه به طبعا عمر البشير رئيس
السوداني المعزول قال بانه يتحمل
المسؤوليه الكامله لما حدث في الثلاثين من
يونيو لعام 89
وانه
المسؤول عن تفجير او قائد ومفجر ثوره
الانقاذ الوطني وانه لم يكن لاي عضو في
مجلس قياده الثوره اي دور في احداث
الثلاثين من يونيو
عوده الى سياق نشرتنا حتى وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي بني جونز المجتمع الدولي
للتعامل مع ايران كما يتعامل النيترو في
اوكرانيا
ايران تشكله اولا تهديدا للعالم والاقليم
ومن ثم لاسرائيل وشدد جنس كذلك على ضروره
تكفيف التعامل العسكري
ضد ايران قبل الحصول على السلاح النووي
مطالبا في هذا الشان المجتمع الدولي
الجمعه بين القوه واستعراض القوه في
التعامل مع ايران
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان افاد بمقتل
شخصين يرجح انهما يعملان مع حزب الله
اللبناني نتيجه ضربات اسرائيليه قرب مطار
دمشق الدولي ومحيط العاصمه السوريه ووضح
المرصد ان الغارات استهدفت فجر اليوم
مستودع اسلحه ومواد اللوجستيه لحزب الله
اللبناني ضمن مزرعه تقع ما بين السيده
زينب والبيجداليه مما ادى الى تدميرها
بشكل كامل وسط المعلومات عن وجود العديد
من القتلى في الموقع من القاهره لا ينضم
الينا الباحث في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه احمد عليبه اهلا
بك سيد احمد معنا ماذا تريد تحديدا
اسرائيل من المجتمع الدولي الى اي مدى هذه
المخاوف الاسرائيليه داخل سوريا مشروعه
حاليا
بتحاول تفسر هذا الموقف الخاص بالكثير من
التطورات اللي يمكن وصفها عفيف كخافي بانه
همم التوقيت حارج بالنسبه لاسرائيل في
التعامل مع الوضع الايراني ومحاوله ايران
تعزيز وجودها في سوريا وايضا من خلال
الدور اللي بيقوم به حزب الله في لبنان
حاليا وهمم يعني احدث مؤشراته حادث اليونا
فعلا
باعتقد انه
السياق هنا بيرتبط بالتوقيتها بالتطورات
المتعدده جزء منها انه همم اسرائيل بتحتاج
الى دعم دولي خاصه وانه هي شايفه النموذج
الروسي الاوكراني لانه هي ما تقدرش ان هي
توامر فيها هذه المنطقه بشن عمليه عسكريه
ضد ايران في الوقت اللي ممكن ما يكونش في
دعم لهذه العمليه
وتحديدا ده ايضا في سياق الرسائل الداخليه
همم الخاصه بي او التطورات الداخليه في
اسرائيل خاصه به عوده بنيامين نتانيا او
لانه عنده موقف واضح انه مش شرط ان يتم
همم يعني همم يعني همم مجرد اختار
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بتوجيه عمليه عسكريه ضد ايران هي ممكن
تتوقف عند الاخطار لكن مش شرط ان تكون
عمليات منثقه لكن وزاره الدفاع عندها موقف
اخر انه اي تحرك في هذا الشكل لازم يكون
منسق وانه يعني في ترتيبات لهذا الامر
المنوره
الماضي
الاسرائيليه او المطالبات الاسرائيليه الى
اي مداهيه واقعيه من يتفق معها ومن يختلف
بالتاكيد هناك اتفاق في الساق العام لكن
هناك تباينات في وجهات النظر بمعنى انه
احنا ايضا امام تطور خاص بالملف النووي
الايراني في ضوء زياره وافد فني من
الوكاله الدوليه الى طهران ايضا امام
تصريحات لوزير الخارجيه ايراني
في اطار اللقاء مع جوزها بوريل
باعتقد انه هذا التطور ان ايران بتحاول
ترجع خطوه الى الوراء في ظل التوترات
الداخليه
ربما ايضا هي بتحاول ان هي تتقدم على
جابها بعيده عن ايران الى حد ما في سوريا
ولبنان وبالتالي تحاول ان هي يعني تربك
اسرائيل في هذه الساحه باكثر من شكل ولكن
تصل الى هذه هل يمكن ان ينقل او يعيد
المواجهه الى الداخل الايرانيه يعني انت
تقول ان ايران تحاول ان تبعد المواجهه عن
اراضيها ولكن هل يمكن ان نرى ضربه ايليا
مباشره للداخل الايراني ان ستكتفي ايران
بعفوا اسرائيل بضرب المليشيات والمستودعات
الايرانيه للاسلحه العسكريه
اعتقد انه خلص يعني منهم سيناريو قائمه
ومنهم سيناريو وارد يعني الضربات التي
وجهت من الجانب الاسرائيلي في سوريا على
سبيل المثال بدا ان تكون اكثر كثافه اكثر
تحديدا تتوسع ايضا في مناطق مثل حلب وتصل
الى الحدود العراقيه السوريه من جانب اخر
المساله الجاده الاولى انه يمكن همم يعني
انهاء مسار حروب الظل التي لم تعد فعله
بشكل كبير وانه مساله العوده الى الاتفاق
النووي بالشكل الذي قد لا ترغب في اسرائيل
ربما يغير في الحسابات الاسرائيليه عوده
نتنياهو مره اخرى ومحاوله الهيمنه على
القرار الامن بشكل كبير وبالتالي لا يمكن
استبعادها هذا الامر لكنه يتوقف ايضا على
مدى قوه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
لاعب دور في هذه المساله لانه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ترى ان مساله توجيه
ضربه عسكريه ليه ايران تحتاج الى حسابات
كثيره بيت مختلفه هناك خطه مشتركه ما بين
الطرفين لكن هذه الخطه يعني ستكون في
توقيت معين لا اعتقد انه الوقت متاحه
الامريكيه ترى ان التوقيت الحالي هو
التوقيت مناسب توقيت غير مناسب يا سيد
احمد ورفض اسرائيلي قاطعه
لاتفاق النووي بشكله الحالي اذا ما مصير
هذا الاتفاق برايك سريعا لو سمحت
لا يزال من المبكر انه يعني تحصل تحدث
ناقله نوعيه في هذا المسار لكن انا اعتقد
انه ايران بحاجه الى ان تستفيد من الوقت
الحالي فيما يعتقد ان هي قد تنتهي فرصه
لكن لا اتصور ذلك في حقيقه الامر هو سوف
يكون مصيره على الارجح مثل المفاوضات
السابقه شكرا في وحده الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه في مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه احمد عليبه
انطلقت في عدد من المدن الايرانيه تظاهرات
ليليه مردده شعارات مناهضه للنظام فيما
احرق محتجون مقرا للفاسد وصوره لقاسم
سليماني في مدينه قم
ح
فارس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ياسين ياسين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يفتحوا ليه زوج
وني
[تصفيق]
لجنه دعم فرنسيين معتقلين في ايران دعت في
رساله الى الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
الى تحرك منسق من جانب الدول الاوروبيه
وشددت اللجان المشاهدين في هذه الرساله
المفتوحه على الاقرار انا الاستراتيجيه
تفوضيه الفرنسيه حتى الان لم تفضي الى اي
نتيجه كبيره وتفيد السلطات الفرنسيه انها
تمت سبعه فرنسيين معتقلين في ايران بينهم
المدرسه والنقابيه سيسيل كولر وشريك
حياتها جاك بيري
من لندن ينضم الينا الباحث في الشان
الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن اهلا بك سيد
وجدان اذا دعوات لتحرك اوروبي منسق ضد
ايران للافراج عن المعتقلين الاوروبيين في
الداخل الايراني خصوصا وان كما ذكرنا
الاستراتيجيه التفاوضيه الفرنسيه لم تجدي
اي نتيجه حتى الان ماذا جديه القاده
الاوروبيين في استعاده مواطنهم من السجون
الايرانيه
الكرام طبعا
الجهود التي تكون مشتركه ومناسبات تاتي
بثمارها وهذا ما شاهدناه في اكثر من ملف
ضد النظام الايراني فيما يتعلق في موضوع
اللجنه الشؤون المراه في ما يتعلق في
موضوع مجلس حقوق الانسان وتشكيل الاجنه
همم ضد النظام الايراني وايضا همم
التحركات الجماعيه لا شك انها تاتي
بثمارها همم الدول الاوروبيه عملت بشكل
منفرد كل دوله بمفردها همم لمطالبه النظام
الايراني
بالافراجلها في داخل السجون الايرانيه
لكنها لم تاتي همم
حتى بعض الدول الاوروبيه منها بلجيكا
حاولت ان تقوم بتسليم ايران المجرم مقابل
الفراش عن المعتقلين وهذا ما جعل النظام
الايراني ان يستقل هذه همم هذه الفرصه
ونقاط الضعف الاوروبيه من خلالها اعتقال
همم
الاوروبيين لكسب امتيازات
الاوروبيه او القاده الاوروبيين القاده
الاوروبيون لا يلتزمون
بالتبادل او او مطالبه بمواطنهم من ايران
لان ايران تستخدم ذلك كانت الضغط عليهم
الشديد نعم النظام الايراني يستخدمها
اوراق ضغط وايضا حتى احد المرشحين للرئاسه
الجمهوريه همم
هو محسن رضائي قائد الحرس الدوري
وايضا رئيس مكتب مجلس رخيص بمصلحه النظام
اعلنها صراحتا باننا همم في حاله اعتدت
علينا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الغربيه سنقوم باعتقال همم اعداد كبيره
ومن ثم مقابل كل واحد وصف بالمليارات
الدولارات وهذه هي السياسه التي يعتمد
عليها نظام الايراني ولا للاسف نعم بكل
تاكيد ايران نجحت في هذه همم في هذه
السياسيه منذ بدايه الثوره همم
ايرانهم يعني اغلبيتهم الجميع غالبيتهم
اصولهم ايرانيه فهي تتخذ هذه الاجراءات
ايضا تجاه ابناء بلدهم الذين يحملون
الجنسيات المختلفه من الدول الاوروبيه طيب
اذا في ظل كل ذلك ما الخيارات المتاحه
امام القاده الاوروبيين ل اا اا حلها وحل
حاله هذه القضيه
همم
الاوراق يمكن العمل عليها لكن حتى الان لم
يتم استخدامها نقرا بانه اليوم
القاده الايرانيين ابنائهم والكثير من
المسؤولين همم يجدون في الدول الغربيه همم
اما من حيث الاست- الاستثمارات في هذه
الدول او ارسال ابناءهم ويتجاوز اعدادهم
الاف همم من الطلبه وايضا همم الاسر هم في
الدول الغربيه ولديهم ارصده واموال كبيره
جدا اذا كانت الدول الغربيه تريد تضغط على
النظام الايراني يمكنها تهديد ايران بطرد
ابناء المسؤولين الايرانيين تجميد
ارصداتهم همم لا تسمح لهم ان يتواجدوا على
اراضيها يقوم بالدعايه للنظام الايراني
وايضا الدعم الاقتصاد الايراني من خلال
التبادل التجاري وايضا حتى شاهدنا انه
الكثير من الاختراقات للقرارات
دوليه من ابداء المسؤولين وعوائلهم في
الدول الغربيه اذا كانت الدول الغربيه
بالفعل اتخذت هكذا قرارات لا شك ان النظام
الايراني سيتراجع امام المطالب الاوروبيه
لكن اذا بقت اوروبا كما هي الان لا
اعتقدون ايران يفرج عنها هؤلاء
الموجهه للرئيس ايمانويل سيد وجدان
بالمزيد من الاجراءات وهمم التوحد في
الاجراءات الطائره شكرا لك من لندن الباحث
في الشان الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن
مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل
صندوق النقد الدولي يعلن موافقته على
انشاء برنامج لدعم اوكرانيا لمده اربعه
اشهر
احييكم من جديد اعلن رئيس التنفيذي ومالك
تويتر الى الماسك الاستقاله من رئاسه مجلس
اداره المنصب بعد استفتاء اطلاقه بالامس
على المنصه حول بقائه في منصبه وذلك خلال
البث المباشر عبر حساب تسلافي يوتيوب في
ما لم يصدر اي بيان رسمي عن ماسك حول
استقالته او من قد يخلفه في رئاسه تويتر
من بيروت معنا الدكتور فول مرقص استاذ
القانون الدولي ورئيس منظمه جوستا
الحقوقيه اهلا بك معنا همم دكتور همم يعني
استقاله ماسك يعني تاخذ نفس الخطوات التي
اتخذها سابقا باجراء استفتاء والعمل به
بعد خروج النتائج هذه الاستقاله مع نظرنا
الى تصرفاته سابقا هل كانت متوقعه هل يمكن
ان نتنبا عن اسباب هذه الاستقاله
طبعا الذهب الى الاستفتاء لم يكن متوقعه
لكن يعني الخليفه خليفه هذا الرجل طبعا هي
يعني محل اعتبار من قبله والا لما كان
اقبل او اقدم على هذه الخطوه رغم انه نفق
ان يكون لديه اي خليفه
وقد صرح البارحه انه بصدد التفكير في اا
اداره جديده للمنصه الالكترونيه لكن هكذا
يعني خطوه استراتيجيه لم تكن لتحصن لولا
ااه تبقى طبعا الحسبان المسبق الذي قام به
وحتى انه يعرف كان سلفا ان النتائج لكن
ارادها ربما على نحو همم غير مالوف وجديد
ومتكر ان يخرج هذا الخروج اذا اردت هذا
الاكزيت على نحو يعطي الانتباه بان ثمه
اليه ديمقراطيه وراء ذلك
ولكن ما هي تحديدا هل هي الضغوط الدوليه
التي شاهدناها من الامم المتحده وغيرها ام
هل هي ضغوط من المستثمرين في تسلا او
سبيكس اسبيس اكس وغيره
اعتقد ان دور المستثمرين كان دورا محوريه
تعرفين معي ان المخاطر التي احيطت بملكيه
الاسهم
وقيمه هذه الاسهم مع ادانه الامم المتحده
اداره الاتحاد الاوروبي ادانت المانيا له
وللي تصرفاته من حيث تجميد او تعليق
الحسابات العائده للصحفيين قد اثارت مخاوف
جديه من قبل هؤلاء المستثمرين طبعا ايضا
ان سمكه ايضا يعني ضغط سياسي وراء ذلك
يعني هنالك تلويح كبير في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بتسريع الخطى نحو تعديل
القانون الذي يبيح
للمنصات الالكترونيه هكذا هامش موسع من
الحركه وبالتالي فانهم يستفيدون من
التعديل الدستوري الاول في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الذي يبيع للشركات
الخاصه للقطاع الخاص حريه كبيره اما
الاداره الحكوميه والسياسه والقياده
الحكوميه فانها لا يمكن لها ان تتدخل في
الحريات الخاصه وكانه بذلك يعني اصبح ماسك
هو اللاعب الاول وربما الوحيد على الساحه
يغلق الحسابات ويفتح الحسابات يفتح اكثر
ملفات تتعلق برئيس ابن رئيس
الاتحاد الامريكي
دكتور
وصف باللعب او الركض في السيرك بالتالي من
الرئيس التنفيذي او من خليفه ماسك الذي
يؤهل اومال المؤهلات المطلوبه لخليفه ماسك
لهذا المنصب في ظل الوضع الحالي للمنصه
نعم جرى الحديث حول ذلك وحول الصفات على
الاقل ليس هنالك من اسماء بارزه لغايه
اليوم لكن الصفات هي تعتد بشخصيه يعني
مسالمه شخصيه غير استفزازيه شخصيه اداريه
محط لا يعني تثير اي حساسيه همم
لا يعني تثير
القلاقل او التحدي بالنسبه همم
للمستخدمين بالنسبه للمستثمرين بالنسبه
للقاده السياسيين يعني اعتقد ان المنصه
بحاجه الى اداره جديده تضبط الموازنه تضبط
عدد العاملين فيها همم يعني تضبط مسائل
الحريه على نحو المنظم لكن ايضا على نحو
نبيح ممارسه الحقوق والحريات نحن بحاجه
اعتقد الى مرحله جديده من الاستقرار تؤدي
الى انتعاش
الاسعار لان ما حصل ربما كان ضاره نافعه
يعني هذا يعني تلبك او الحديث المستفيض
حول المنصه ادى طبعا الى تسليط الضوء
عليها اكثر فاكثر
بها
المؤهل لي ينتشر المنصه من هذه الرمال
المتحركه كما وصفوها شكرا لك من بيروت
دكتور باول المرقص استاذ القانون الدولي
ورئيس منظمه جوستيا الحقوقيه
قال نائب السفيره الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده
الايرانيه اعترفت بنقل طائرات مسيره الى
روسيا وان الادله واضحه على استخدام روسيا
لهذه الطائرات في قصه البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في اوكرانيا
في منصوب يا برنس
ارتكبها عضو دائم في هذا المجلس وكشفت
اوكرانيا عن ادله موثوقه تؤكد استخدام
روسيا لطائرات مسيره ايرانيه الصنع
لمهاجمه البنيه التحتيه المدنيه طيران
بدورها وعلى لسان وزير خارجيتها اعترفت في
نوفمبر الماضي بنقل مسيرات الى روسيا
ودعوني اذكركم ان القرار
2231 يحضر نقل هذا النوع من الطائرات من
دون موافقه مجلس الامن المسبقه
الامم المتحده قال من جانبه ان عددا من
الطائرات المسيره ثم نقلها الى روسيا قبل
اندلاع الحرب داعيا الى وقفه حملات
الاتهام والتضليل بشان استخدام هذه
الطائرات في اوكرانيا على حسب قوله
في هذا الموبايلات
في محادثات ثنائيه مع اوكرانيا لتوضيح سوء
التفاهم الحالي بشان طائراتنا المسيره
ولتوضيح فان ايران نقلت عددا من الطائرات
المسيره الى روسيا قبل اندلاع الحرب ولم
يتم نقلها لاستخدامها في الصراع الدائر في
اوكرانيا لذلك يجب انهاء حمله التضليل
والاتهامات ضد طهران والتي لا اساس لها من
الصحه
تزويد بلاده بمجموعه واسعه من انظمه
الاسلحه لتعزيز وتوزيع فعاليات الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه الى ان الدعم العالمي
لاوكرانيا سيزداد في العام المقبل
خلال العام المقبل بنفس الزخم او حتى
بندفاع اكثر وهو بالضبط ما نحتاجه لتعزيز
عملياتنا الدفاعيه نحتاج الى المزيد من
المدافع والقذائف والى الدبابات الحديثه
التي لم نستلم منها بعد بالاضافه الى
انظمه الصواريخ
الدفاع الجوي الحديثه والفحاله
اعلنت نائبه ومدير صندوق النقد الدولي ان
المجلس التنفيذي للصندوق وافق على انشاء
برنامج تمويليا لدعم اوكرانيا مده هذا
البرنامج اربعه اشهر ويهدف لمساعدتها في
تعزيز تمويل المانحين والحفاظ على
الاستقرار الاقتصادي في اعقاب الحربي مع
روسيا
الاتحاد
حد اقصى لاسعار الغاز الطبيعي والقاده
الاسر والشركات على مواجهه ازدياد المفرط
في الاسعار الغاز تحديدا
بعد اشهر انشقت خلافات وانقسامات بين دول
الاتحاد
وتخللتها ضغوط شديده وتهديدات بتفكك السوق
اتفقت الدول الاعضاء حول تحديد سعر السقف
الغاز المستخدم في صناعه الكهرباء عند
مستوى 280 يورو 9
الاليه تفعل اذا تجاوز السعر السقف ثلاثه
ايام متتاليه
في منتصفه فبراير المقبل
في الساعه على مدار ثلاثه ايام عمل ثانيا
اذا تجاوز الفارق بين السعر وفقا مؤشر
الاساسي في السوق العالميه للغاز اذا
تجاوز الفاروق 35 يورو على ثلاثه ايام عمل
الاتفاق يسمى اليه تصحيح السوق
الاليه مؤقته تقتضي زمنيه بعدم تفعيلها
اذا واجهت دوله واحده صعوبات في امدادات
الغاز او اذا ظل السعر في المستويات
المنخفضه وتراجعت والديه الغاز المسال نص
الاتفاق يتضمن المميزات الخاصه باليه
تصحيح السوق مثل ما اقتراحته المفوضيه
لكنه يقتضي حزمه من الضمانات القويه
المفوضيه تعتقد ان هذه الاليه مفيده لكنها
تتضمن مخاطر لذلك وضعنا ضمانه اضافيه
لحمايه مصالح مزودين الغاز المسال
والسيوله واستقرار اسواق المال واستهلاك
الغاز المجر انفردت باعتراضها على الاتفاق
النمس وهولندا اكلتهم احتفالتها بصوتهما
احتياطيات الغاز في السوق الاوروبيه بلغت
مستويات قياسيه
96% بالتالي لا خوف من شتاء هذا العام
المشكله تكمن في احتياطات العام 2023 حيث
سيعاني الاتحاد الاوروبي عزا من الغاز
المسال بنحوي 30 مليار متر مكعب حسب
تقديري وكاله الطاقه الدوليه ما قد يحد من
تاثير اليه تصحيح السوق التي حذيت
بالمصادق هنا
نور الدين العربيه
وقال بوتين في رساله مصوره لوحده الامن
الفيدرالي ان روسيا ستعمل على دعم الوحدات
القتاليه في هذه المناطق باحداث الاسلحه
وشدد على ضروره تكثيف الجهد المخابراتي
والكشف بسرعه عن الجواسيس والمخربين
واحباط هجماتهم بسرعه ذكرت سلطان دنيتك
المواليه لروسيا ان معارك عنيفه تجري
حاليا في الجهه الغربيه من مدينه في دنياك
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت مقاطعه
دوني 250 قذيفه وصاروخا من 52 موقع مختلفا
في الساعات الاخيره من جهه اخرى اكده
مراسل العربيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه
رسالات وحدات عسكريه الى سوليدار في
دونيتك حيث لا تزال المعارك للسيطره على
المدينه مستمره
ونشرتنا ايضا تستمر فيها بعد الفاصل بعد
اربعه عقود من افتتاحها مكتبه الساقي في
لندن تغلق ابوابها لاسباب الاقتصاديه
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يشددوا على ضروره
التعامل العسكري والاستخبارات الدولي ضد
ايران
مع كوريا الجنوبيه
المنتخب الارجنتيني يصل مطار العاصمه
واحتفالات شعبيه ضخمه في استقباله
احييكم من جديد كشف بيان الامن العام
الاردني عن تفاصيل احداث مقتلي ثلاثه من
عناصره خلال محاصره مجموعه ارهابيه في
معان
من جديد فبعد مقتل الضابط الاردني عبد
الرزاق الدلابيح بيومين داهمه القوه
الامنيه القاتل هنا في هذا البيت بمواجهه
افضل لموت ثلاثه رجال من الامن العام
ومقتل قاتل الدلابيح ورغم هدوء يعم المكان
الا ان مشهد الحزن خيم على ثلاث جنازات
هنا بالتحديد تقودك الدماء لمشهد المواجهه
بين القوه الامنيه ومجموعه من الارهابيين
وما بين الرصاص طائش وموجه قضى ثلاثه من
رجال الامن العام واصيب اخرون طبقت قواعد
الاشتباك ورد الامن بقتله احد افراد
الخليه وبعد جمع الادله الفنيه والمخبريه
اكدت التحقيقات انه هو قاتل الضابط عبد
الرزاق الدلابيح الذي قضى برصاصه اثراء
اعمال شغب مفتعله في منطقه الحسينيه ضمن
عمليه ارهابيه خطط لها لاستهدف القوات
الامنيه
اليوم ليس كان البارحه
اطلب من جميع المواطنين الابتعاد عن كل
الاماكن التي تضم اعمال عنف وما بين
محافظه الطفيله ومادبا وعمان شيع
الاردنيون ثلاثه من رجال الامن وسط
مطالبات بالقصاص من الجناه من جهه والعوده
لاسباب تازم الاحداث من جهه اخرى
فردي ليس لابناء اللواء الحسينيه اي علاقه
في هذا الموضوع الحكومه
تركت المشكله من البدايه وما صار فيها
حديث مع المواطنين ولا حلت المشكله لذلك
خسرنا كانت كبيره من البدايه التصرف اللي
حدث هذا التصرف فردي ينعكس الشخص نفسه عدم
تدخل رئيس الحكومه ومماطله الحكومه في
القضيه كامله ادت الى هذا المشهد اللي
انتم تشوفوه الان واللي الان بلشنا نخسر
ابناء سواء في الجهاز الامني او من
المواطنين احداث المواجهات الاخيره دفعت
بالقوه الامنيه لتعزيز وجودها حفاظا على
حياه المواطنين وفرض الامن خاصه مع مراري
مطالبهم في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه لا
تحتمل ذهابا الجميع الى نقطه تضيع فيها
الحقوق وتزداد فيها الاوضاع تازما من
مدينه الحسينيه جنوب العاصمه عمان عماد
العضائله العربيه
ينطلق اليوم مؤتمر بغداد للتعاون والشراكه
في دورته الثانيه وذلك في العاصمه
الاردنيه عمان وبمشاركه عدد من قاده الدول
وسيبحث المؤتمر سبل دعم العراق والجهود
التي يقوم بها من اجل تعزيز امره وسيادته
وضمان استقراره وتحقيق التنميه والرخاء
لشعبه بالاضافه الى تطبيق اليات التعاون
الاقليميه مع العراق عدد من المجالات التي
تشمل مكافحه الارهاب والامن الغذائي الامن
المائي والطاقه وغيرها من المجالات التي
تسهم في دعم العراق واخيرا سيبحث ايضا
المؤتمر مشاهدينا اليات التعاون
الاقليميات التي تحقق التكامل والامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه
في ظروف معيشيه صعبه يعاني النازحون في
مارب وتزداد اوضاعهم قساوه مع كل توسع
لدائره الحرب
ليت لها من اسمها نصيب هكذا تقول سعيده
المقعده في مخيم السويداء
والنازحه في دروب التعاسه منذ ثمان سنوات
من حريب منهم الى هنا مرت سعيده وابنائها
باربع محطات نزوح كانت جميعها وسط نيران
الاشتباكات ومع كل محطه كانت تتوفر فيها
الخدمات تصلوا المقذوفات والحوثيه لتجبرهم
على تغيير مخيم النزوح وبدء معاناته جديده
وحيات الناس
وجه الله يتجمع الاحفاد حول سعيده التي
اصبحت بحالها هذا المربيه الاطفال
في الحرب اطفال لا يجدون في خيام مم قد ما
يقيهم قسوه البرد في مناطق صحراويه مفتوحه
لي نتنافض ولا راح تضيف فوق البطانيه
كانوا فوق البطانيه من البرد من هذا البرد
عسر الحمد لله
81,000 اسره في المخيمات معرضاه لموقت همم
البرد الشديده منها 60000 واسره بحاجه
شديده وماسه همم
لاحتياجات الايواء والماء منها الحقائب
الشتويه ووسائل التدفئه الاخرى همم مثل
همم الشتويه
ومواد الايواء الفرشان والبطانيات وغيرها
من الادوات
بلد ماربو اكثر من مليونين نازح هجرتهم
المليشيات الحوثيه من محافظات مختلفه لكن
المعاناه الاشد هي تكرار النزوح داخليه
بين مديريات المحافظه لا تنحصر المعاناه
على مخيمات النازحين فقط فماربوا بمدينتها
واطرافها تجمع كبير لنزوح محمود الحميدي
لقناه العربيه مارب
الى تونس والتي شهدت انتخابات تشريعيه
مؤخرا واعلنت الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات عن الذهاب الى دور ثاني من
الانتخابات التشريات طبعا بعد تاجيل حسب
الدوري الاول في اكثر من 130 دائره
انتخابيه والغاء عدد من النتائج جزئيا او
حتى كليا بسبب مخالفات انتخابيه الرئيس
سعيد رد بدوره على المشككين في نجاح
الانتخابات وسط جدل سياسي وقانوني حول نسب
المشاركه فيها
صناديق الاقتراع تبوح باسرارها في اول
انتخابات تشريعيه بعد الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه في البلاد مجلس هيئه
الانتخابات يعلنوا ان نسبه المشاركه بلغت
11.22% وعن المرور الى دور ثاني من هذه
الانتخابات قبل تركيز البرلمان الجديد
سجلت الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
قيام مليون وخمسه وعشرين الف
1418 ناخب ايامهم بحق التصويت والادلاء
باصواتهم في جميع المكاتب والمراكز بنسبه
اقبال
11.22%
مجلس هيئه الانتخابات اعلن ان الدوره
الثانيه من التشريعيه سيشمل اكثر من 130
دائره انتخابيه مع تسجيل
1750 مخالفه اثرت على سير الانتخابات
الرئيس قيس سعيد رد على المطالبين بابطال
الانتخابات بالقول ان نسبه المشاركه لا
تقاس فقط بالدور الاول بل بالدورتين معا
معتبرا ان هذا الموقف صادر عن جهات لا داب
لها الا التشكيك ليتواصل الجدل سياسيا
وقانونيا على اعتبار اهميه الاستحقاق
التشريعيه في البلاد
النخبه التونسي ذهب على مراحل في البدايه
هناك التصويت قوي بل قوي على الانتخابات
ثم ذهب نحو التصويت العقابي الذي حدث في
سنه 2014 ثم 2019 واليوم هو يذهب الى
مقاطعه هذه الانتخابات نعم وحوار الوطني
صحيحه يهم الجانب الاقتصادي والاجتماعي ثم
نتفهم ولا القاعده السياسيه الجديده
واللعبه السياسيه جديده منها القانون
الانتخابي للنجم يكون هذا الافراد ولكن
يتغير
وستعلموا النتائج النهائيه للانتخابات
التشريعيه في التاسعه عشر من شهر جانفي
كانون الثاني القادم بعد حسم مساله تطيعون
قضائيا واجراء الدور الثاني بدايه شهر في
افريقيا مع الاعلاني عن النتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات التشريعيه يؤجل الحسم في تركيز
البرلمان الجديد الى دوره ثانيه لذلك
سياسيا وقانونيا رافق العمليه خاصه وانها
اخر المحطات في مشروع الرئيس سعيد لانهاء
الفتره للاستثناء
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
مباشره الى اخبار الاقتصاد مع الزميل ناصر
الكلمه له
1 في المئه حتى هذه اللحظه عند عتبه
العشره الاف نقطه لم نكسرها بعد بالنسبه
للتداولات الجلسه هذا اليوم هذه نظره ايضا
على التراجعات التي نشهد في الاسواق
الاخرى تحديدا في سوق الكويت الاول حيث
نشهد بان هناك تراجعات واسعه همم في
مكونات هذا المؤشر خلال الجلسه تراجعات في
ابو ظبي باربعه اشهر استقرار في دبي وبعض
المكاسب على كل من مؤشرين الدوحه ومسقط
ماذا عن الاسهم في همم السوق السعوديه
الاكثر تداوله من حيث القيمه سابك
للمغذيات الزراعيه التوزيعات بثمان ريالات
عن السهم عن النصف الثاني طبعا كان مجلس
الاداره في همم بدايه همم اوصى بتوزيعات
باربع ريالات لكن اضاف اربع ري لا اخرى
وذلك بسبب الاداء المالي المتميز للشركه
في النصف الثاني مع ارتفاع اسعار الاسمده
التي شاهدناها في ضوء الحرب اا في
اوكرانيا هذه احدى التداعياتها كبلات
الرياض حاليا على ارتفاع بثلاثه في المئه
بعد ادراجها في جلسه البارحه وانخفاضها ب
12% لكن حتى اللحظه ما زالت دون سعر
الاكتتاب عند 43 ريال همم تراجع على سهم
المعادن بواحد وربع مجموعه تداول ايضا
متراجعه بثلاثه في المئه والاسهم المصرفيه
لا تزال ايضا همم متراجعه انخفاضاتها منذ
همم نهايه سبتمبر وحتى اليوم نتحدث عن 14%
مؤشر البنوك في الجلسه لهذه التراجعات
باكثر من اثنين ونصف % على الرياض وعلى
الاهلي همم بالنسبه لسهم سابك بعض المكاسب
بنصف النقطه المئويه مخالف الاتجاه العام
للسوق سابك همم مكاسبه نصف نقطه مئويه
وايضا في قطاع الاتصالات تراجعات على اس
تي سي باثنين في المئه وعلى اتحاد موبايلي
وزين باكثر من واحد في المئه سريعا في دبي
اعمار متراجعه بنصف النقطه المئويه دي
واليوم اخر يوم
للاستحقاقات التوزيعات تبريد مكاسب بخمسه
في المئه
والاسهم في ابو ظبي الفاظا بسهم الاكثر
نشاطا تراجعات على ابو ظبي للموانئ وملطي
بلاي بواحد فاصل اربعه في المئه وفي السوق
الكويتيه معظم الاسهم الرئيسيه على انخفاض
بيتك واحد ونصف النقطه المئويه جيلاتي
بحوالي اثنين في المئه ورده ايضا تراجعات
بثلاثه ونصف النقطه ال- مئويه هذه كانت
اغلاقات اسيا صباح هذا اليوم ونظر سريع
على اسعار النفط التي كانت لا تزال برينتي
يتداول عند قرابه 80 دولار الان خف خفف من
هذه المستويات الى 79$ ونصف الدولار هذه
كانت مشاهدينا اذا همم وقفتنا مع الاسواق
نعود الان من جديد الى استديوهاتنا في
الرياض مع كيف فاطمه
عدا منتخب الارجنتين الى بلاده بعد تحقيقه
لكاس العالم لهذا العام وانتظر في مطار
العاصمه بونارس الاف من المواطنين
والاعلاميين وبعد فوزهم على فرنسا في
نهائي كاس العالم الاحد في مباراه كانت
مشوقه سيمضي اللاعبون ليلتهم في مجمع
تدريب الاتحاد الارجنتيني لكره القدم قرب
المطار في العاصمه الارجنتينيه حيث
ينتظرهم الاف المشجعين للترحيب بهم ثم
سيبداون جوله في وسط العاصمه الارجنتينيه
اعتبارا من ظهر الثلاثاء بتوقيتهم
الدواء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
البرديله
[موسيقى]
اصبحت الهيئه الحكوميه في ولايتي
اريزونارجينيا احدث من يفرض حظرا على
استخدام تطبيق تيك توك لمقاطع الفيديو
القصيره على الاجهزه التابعه لحكمتهما
بسبب مخاوف من امكانيه ان تستخدمه الصين
لتتبع الامريكيين ومراقبه المحتوى ومنعاه
حكومه اريزونا وحكومه وسترجينيا تسعه عشره
ولايه امريكيه بشكل جزئيه على الاقل
الوصول الاجهزه التي تستخدمها حكومات تلك
الولايات الى منصه تيك توك الصينيه
وزاره الخارجيه الكوريه الشماليه رددت
باستراتيجيه اليابان الامنيه الجديده
واتهمتها مشاهدينا باحداث تغيير جذري في
بيئه المنطقه الامنيه وحذرت بيومي من انها
ستتخذ اجراءات ملموسه لتبرهن حجم خطا
وخطوره اجراءات اليابان العسكريه
كشف بنك انجلترا النقابه عن اوراق جديده
بالجنيه الاسترليني مع صوره الملك
البريطاني تشارلز الثالث والتي من المتوقع
ان يتم تداولها في منتصف عام 2024 واضاف
البنك انه ستتم طباعه الاوراق النقديه
الجديده بقيمه خمسه جنيهات وعشره جنيهات
و20 جنيه و50 جنيه
استرليني فقط بعد اكثر من اربعه عقود في
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن اعلنت مكتبه
الساقيه انها ستغلق ابوابها نهايه ديسمبر
لتنتهي بذلك تجربه مضيئه في خدمه الثقافه
العربيه في اوروبا
ومديره دار الساقي سلوى الاقفال الى عدم
قدره العرب والمقيمين في لندن على تحمل
كلفه شراء الكتب من جهه والى الاعباء
الاقتصاديه المتزايده في بريطانيا من جهه
ثانيه وتامل ينجح الجيل الجديد من الشباب
في بناء تجربه تجربه مكتبه
[موسيقى]
بعد اربعه 44 عاما جمعت خلالها مكتبه
الساقيه عرباوه التعبان ومثقفين من مختلف
انحاء العالم تغلق المكتبه نهايه ديسمبر
محلها الاكبر في اوروبا
لم تعد قادره على اكمال مشوارها بسبب
اعباء بريطانيا الاقتصاديه المتزايده
العرب
[موسيقى]
السياسيه في المنطقه العربيه والعالم و
باتت ملجا للعديدين للتعبير عن ارائهم او
احتجاجاتهم
ما في حدا يكسرنا قزايز المكتب يكسروا لنا
الواجهه لانه في كتاب ما عجبوه او حديث
يقول لك ممنوع الموسيقى
[موسيقى]
لا يسمع احد خبر اغلاق المكتبه دون شعوري
بغصه خسارتي كنز ثقافيه
القراءه واشتغل في المكاتبك عده
تتركو سلوى مكتبه الساقيه على امل تسليم
شعلتها الثقافيه لجيل شاب يقدر ما انتجته
المكتبه من تجربه غنيه تشرف الثقافه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى هذه المكتبه مكتبه دار الساقي تغلق
ابوابها بعد اكثر من اربعين عاما تطورت
فيها التكنولوجيا بسرعه فائقه جعلت من
المطبوعات الورقيه والمحافظه على شغفي بها
عبئا في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه تمر بها
بريطانيا
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
في الختام نذكر بالعناوين
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يشددوا على ضروره
التعامل العسكري والاستخباراتيه الدولي ضد
ايران
القاذفات الامريكيه والمقاتلات تنضم الى
مناورات مشتركه مع كوريا الجنوبيه
المنتخب الارجنتيني يصل مطار العاصمه
واحتفالات شعبيه ضخمه في استقباله
شكرا لطيب المتابعه في امان الله